Okay, now in order to go further, let us start thinking in terms of,
how we can put all of these precepts and goal, into some feature value language,
so that we can store it inside Sole. It is one attempt at capturing all of
this knowledge, so I can say that it's the 7th inning. Inning is 7th.
It's the top of the 7th inning. It's the top here. Runners are on 2nd and
3rd base. 2nd and 3rd base. And then so on and
so forth. Note that at the bottom I have goal is to escape the inning.
Which I think means in this particular context, to go to the next inning,
without letting the batter score anymore points. So now that we have. Put all of
this precepts coming from the world and the goal, into some kind of simple
representation which has features and values in it, the fun is going to begin.